et puis aussi mais moi je te dirai pas
ta gueule mais ça fait rien n'est ce pas
un peu pareil quand même je disais il ya
deux choses film très vite
mais la dame très vite j'étais j'ai
conscience avez de chance vous savez
l'argent et le sexe ou puisqu'on est en
temps nous l'aurait le cucquois c'était
m donc j rage
je me suis rebellé contre la femme est
alors on vous dit catherine paysan il
dit des choses qui me surprend deuxième
constatation il ya 90% de compte 10%
deux frères les frères mais chez les
femmes c'est gratiné j'ai rencontré des
esprits sous payant chez les femmes mais
1% il ya un ramassis de kaunas je ne te
dis que ça c'est quand des choses qu'on
peut si vous voulez vraiment je
m'appelle m'empêche de sauter nous
passons tous d'été glace parce que de
temps en temps quelques mots quand elle
nous en verrons au hockey ciao
au revoir
ok mais finalement il n'y a pas
tellement la bouteille jetée comme
américaine voulait pas d'emblée la
maladie
monsieur foot il fallait mettre en forme
de griffe à des mecs de lute pour il a
porté ces boues thé à la menthe et si
vous tapez que c'était le geste et la
télévision qui l'ignorent il a porté lui
même se douter que je répare pour
apporter son ange et moi
une pas tellement parce que au fond bon
soyons tous tolérant vous avez cette
vision des femmes c'est votre droit
d'autres peuvent avoir une autre vision
d'afar le jugeons je nous voyais bien de
toute façon c'est différent je dois me
suis toujours sortie légale des hommes
mais je pense qu'il faut pas confondre
d'égalité et d'identité